now what we're going to establish first
thing we've got three whole periods to
do this right I want to establish an
overall strategy that's going to work
that's going to be effective in helping
us tackle all the different rates of
change questions we're going to get I
could have given you this yesterday I
could have given you this before we
touched our first question but there's a
really important reason this is why I
don't want your pens your heads for a
second there's a really important reason
why I withheld it from you think about
this for a second we've done this before
right
if you meet a question and you're like
I've never seen this question before and
you say how do I do this and someone
gives you here's a recipe here steps one
through five right
once you go all the way through you will
get an answer out okay and we do that
sometimes I'm probably a common recent
example think about this think about a
kind of topic that we did recently where
there is a highly structured set of
steps that you go through every single
time what topic do we do recently
mathematical induction
right now we told you okay here's step
one here's step to his we in the outline
the whole thing
a part of the reason why is because you
it's really hard to kind of make up
induction whoever did is really really
smart we do not expect you guys this is
centuries of mathematical thought that's
gone into that okay when it comes to
rates of change you've actually been
dealing with all of the main ingredients
of this and I want you to have a look at
your working examples now right now
you've seen all of these ingredients to
keep the metaphor going in the past
you've worked with them quite thoroughly
think about the things that you know
have a look at what was the very first
one I gave you I can't even remember now
was it the it was the was it the balloon
the balloon was what we're thinking
about right what kinds of pieces of
knowledge did you have to draw on to
have a look at the balloon not a
rhetorical question have a think
okay we needed some formula that's right
we wanted the surface area of a sphere
we wanted the volume of a sphere so you
just needed to know those yeah now you
do know those you've let them a long
time ago all right that's good so you
knew some measurement formulas what else
did you need to know have a look at the
question have a look at what you did as
you went through the question poor you
can shout out sure that you can shout
out something else so you can see that
okay we needed today how to
differentiate you're so good at this now
you look at it you forget all this is a
thing I didn't used to know how to do
but you know now right you didn't know
how to differentiate you need to know
how to do chain rule right because
remember we sort of threaded all these
derivatives together right now you know
all of these things which is why I
wanted to put you a little bit in the
deep end before giving you this because
if you get given this and then off you
go you can sort of fall into the trap of
just becoming a bit of a machine that
just does rules okay but we want you to
be a bit better than that right now that
you have encountered these I want to put
together or what is an overall strategy
that does actually work can we see what
you've actually been doing and put some
names on this okay good morning Michael
nice you joining us go sit all right let
me give you some let me give you some
verbs that will describe what we
actually been doing okay so here's the
first thing we did we had to identify a
bunch of things now we have a look at
the question the two kinds of things are
particularly interested in are constants
and variables constants and variables
now if you have a feedback to say the
balloon right we had lots of variables
there we had things like that well tell
me what kinds of things vary when we
were looking at the balloon the radius
varied the Porsche yeah it's it that's
it's it's mirrored isn't it she can't
see you just just push harder that's
okay then the radius changed what else
the volume changed the surface area
change they all changed right now when
you have a look at the Rays we've got a
whole bunch of them we call the V a R
let cetera right I want to make a I'll
use a different color key I want to make
a special note that not all variables
are created equal right some variables
are more fundamental than others they
lead to the others changing right so in
the case of the sphere would probably be
the radius that's the most important
variable it's the fundamental the basic
one and it leads to all of the rest of
them okay when we think about constants
some of the questions you've been having
a look at for example there might be a
cylinder and it might have a constant
radius but its height can change or
something like that okay so some values
in there they don't change and you need
to know what they are what was the most
important closet that you tended to find
in the questions we were having a look
at okay
now you've got the the constant of
integration which sort of comes up but
there will often be a constant that's
actually provided to you a number given
to you in the question think back to the
balloon there was a number I gave you
the value was 70 but what was it what
was 17 minutes signified
more often than not it's a rain right
it's a rate of change I think we were
talking about blowing air into the
balloon so that's how much air is going
into there or we talked about you ever
we looked at the cube the cube and it
was shrinking right what was the what
was the constant in that case it was the
think you've got the question in front
of you wielded it together what's what's
changing it a constant rate it's the
side length and it was shrinking it was
reducing at that rate right so you need
to identify these these are in pretty
important okay after you've identified
okay I then want you to state the
relevant equations so right now you've
got a whole bunch of pronumerals flying
around you know what they are but you
want to relate those prony rules in
particular equations right now because
most of what we're looking at is
geometric right these are these tend to
be I mean you told me just now surface
area volume perimeter things like that
so these generally are measurement
equations of some kind
sometimes you're expected to just know
them like volume and surface area of a
sphere other times they will provide it
to you but in any case you have to
actually state what those equations are
sometimes you got to think of yourself
okay now last major step what did you
then do to actually I mean this is a
rates of change questions so what did
you do to all of this stuff to actually
start working on it you just say it you
have to do some things right you have to
differentiate sometimes you might even
integrate right so we're going to use
some calculus here right so we're going
to determine and calculate the relevant
derivatives or integrals and that kind
of thing and
can you put in an underlying as well
underneath the word determine because we
know how to calculate derivatives we
know how to use the rules but it's just
as important to be able to say oh okay
I'm after Dr on DT that's the thing I'm
after what are the other derivatives
that will help me get to dr/dt I might
have to know DV DT that might be
provided earlier and then I have to get
from DV or DT to dr/dt how am I going to
do that and you're going to have to
determine what other derivatives you
actually need okay